boa noite eu sou professora mas eu fiz
arquitetura e teve o privilégio de ser
aluna de ariano suassuna e todo o
intervalo de aula eu ficava incomodando
o professor adriano pra conversar sobre
as obras dele até que um dia ele um
pouquinho sem paciência deu pra mim e
disse assim você é um peixe fora d'água
aí eu percebi que adriano queria dizer
que não me via como arquiteta
eu busquei um curso que matasse aquela
minha sede e fiz letras e no primeiro
dia que eu dei uma aula eu descobri que
era um peixe dentro de um oceano
eu me senti acolhida eu pertencia àquele
lugar e aí eu vi como as palavras têm
poder
eu sou um apaixonado pela língua
portuguesa e sou apaixonada pelas
palavras eu acho que todo mundo tem que
tratá los muito bem por isso eu gosto de
falar de comunicação adequada e aí eu
fico pensando o que seria uma
comunicação adequada muitos é que diriam
é uma comunicação correta e é verdade
até porque eu tenho certeza que muitos
ler alguma coisa hoje escrever alguma
coisa hoje e se o texto estava 99%
correto o que gritou os olhos foi aquele
1% incorreto ea gente tem como desculpa
que a língua portuguesa é uma das mais
difíceis do mundo é verdade mas ela
também é muito generosa
só que as palavras têm poder ariano
suassuna me ensinou isso e nós
precisamos cuidar bem dessas palavras e
sim uma boa comunicação ela tem que ser
correta a gente precisa utilizar a
generosidade da língua a nosso favor
então se naquele dia você está cansado
você por alguma razão não sabe se
empecilho é com ela o iel ii
você não vai arriscar você simplesmente
substituir por um sinônimo colocar
obstáculo problema sobre correção uma
das dúvidas mais freqüentes é o uso da
vírgula e sinal de pontuação gente não
tem nada de inocente ele pode mudar o
sentido de uma frase
eu tenho uma dica sempre muito boa pra
dar todo mundo que me ouvir
até porque é muito comum a gente é
dúvida e às vezes a gente não tem tempo
de tirar a dúvida ea gente precisa
clicar em enviar para aquele texto
seguir se ao escrever seu texto você
tiver dúvida se ali tem aquela vírgula
se aquele até aquela crazy se aquela
palavra tenha sinto isso não é possível
reescrever de um jeito que a dúvida seja
superada
minha dica é não coloque não coloca a
vírgula não coloca o acento grave no ar
não coloca o acento quem receber seu
texto vai pensar sim ela estava
apressada talvez hoje ela esteja num dia
muito estressante porque ela esqueceu a
crase ela esqueceu a vírgula ela
esqueceu a cento
mas esse foi o contrário e se você
coloca cras e coloca vivo e coloca o
acento equivocadamente ninguém vai dizer
que é porque você estava apressado ou
estressado
vão dizer que você não domina a língua
portuguesa mas também exagera com essa
dica não viu que eu dei essa dica pra
meu sobrinho que se preparou comigo pro
vestibular ficou comigo só seis semanas
casa de ferreiro espeto de pau né então
pegava rodrigo de baixo do prédio pagava
um lanche levava ele para o curso ficou
seis semanas melhorou um pouquinho texto
mas aí minha irmã foi chamada no colégio
a coordenação disse venha que conversar
quando eles chegaram à minha irmã e
rodrigo havia uma redação na mão da
coordenadora e ela disse assim veja
rodrigo até melhorou um pouquinho mas
ele conseguiu escrever um texto de 27
linhas sem nenhuma vírgula
ele disse assim graças a deus ele não
disse meu nome minha gente eles minha
dinda disse que na dúvida eu não
colocasse veja só
ninguém pode ter tanta dúvida mas é uma
dica muito boa
uma outra coisa que uma comunicação além
de correta ela precisa ser objetiva ea
gente fala muito a gente escreve muito
para dizer pouco e uma das falhas mais
comuns na comunicação que ferem a
objetividade são espionagem
as redundâncias eu tenho certeza que
muitos aqui hoje passaram e mails e eu
acho até que alguns usar a expressão
segue anexo
pense um pouquinho sobre isso se está
anexado cio
segue anexo é irmão gêmeo de hemorragia
de sangue
da próxima vez que você for escrever um
e-mail e lugar segue anexa à planilha
escreva somente a next a planilha e
ganha mais objetividade deixe seu texto
mais enxuto repense expressões como ou
seja isto é ou melhor nós usamos essas
expressões explicativas para dizer o que
a gente já disse de outra maneira
das duas uma ou você não foi claro na
primeira vez você está subestimando a
capacidade de quem recebe seu texto de
de entender na primeira leitura na
melhor escrever conseguir mais
objetividade
agora veja a pleonasmos que são figuras
de linguagem fabulosas fernando pessoa
escreveu o mar salgado quanto do teu sal
são lágrimas de portugal
meus alunos mais novos quando escuto
esse poema dizem assim professora e se a
fernando pessoa
eu digo é é desde que você gosta e digo
sim ele não sabe que o mais salgado e eu
explico quando pessoa escreveu esse
poema portugal passava por uma guerra e
as mães portuguesas choravam tanto e
eram tantas as lágrimas que pôde encher
um mar e eu explico pra eles que
pleonasmo com intenção da ênfase à
emoção
mas no nosso texto profissional e não é
bem vindo
então a comunicação adequada ela precisa
ser corretas e objetiva
mas ela tem que ser principalmente clara
e clareza é uma das melhores
características de uma comunicação
adequada
só que a gente deixou de ser simples
porque a gente começou a confundir e
erudição com inteligência rebuscamento
parece coisa de quem escreve e fala bem
pessoal alguém liga para sua sala
perguntando por um colega que acabou de
sair esse colega você atende diz assim
felipe ele não cinco
contra si acaba de chamar felipe de
doido felipe está por aí se procurando
ele não se encontra quando foi que a
gente simplesmente deixou de dizer
filipe ele não está a comunicação
adequada ela tem que ser correta
objetiva e clara e nós vamos ser os
melhores comunicadores do mundo
se nós respeitarmos três elementos o
interlocutor o assunto e o ambiente se
mudar um desses três elementos gente a
gente tem que mudar o jeito de falar
você não fala em casa com seu filho como
você fala com um colega no mercado de
trabalho
você não usa a mesma linguagem por um
bilhete que deixa para o marido para
preparar o seu currículo que vai
disputar uma vaga porque não é adequado
é com roupa você não usa na praia que
usa na igreja
você não usa na balada que usa no
trabalho porque não é adequado
nós precisamos cuidar melhor da língua
portuguesa porque é nossa identidade
nós precisamos saber tratar as palavras
porque elas têm poder
eu acredito muito em palavras de
empoderamento eu acho que mulheres não
são ilhas elas são pontes e acho que
falar bem a característica feminina que
mulheres não precisam gritar para a
cimpor
no geral elas não dizem palavrão para
criticar mesmo numa língua que é
essencialmente masculina porque
privilegiam masculino plural se
perguntarem a respeito dessa
apresentação talvez alguém diga eles
gostaram mesmo havendo mais mulheres
presentes do que homens mas a gente é
muito maior que isso
a gente chega a rir de expressões como
boa noite a todas ea todos
não é verdade e aí a gente fica pensando
que nós somos protagonistas destes novos
tempos
nenhuma mulher pode passar a caneta para
o outro escrever a história dela quem
escreve a nossa história somos nós e eu
desejo que no livro da vida de vocês só
palavras de sucesso estejam inscritas
obrigada
[Aplausos]